Researchers at Cornell decided to figure out
some practical uses for an extra robotic arm.
They discovered it’s more useful for professional
and work settings where it’s helpful to
hold multiple things at once rather than recreational
uses like an extra arm for rock climbing.
Although that would be cool.
And also at Guy Hoffman’s Lab, Blossom is
a social home robot made out of soft, handcrafted
materials like yarn and wood instead of the
usual plastic, glass and metal.
Honestly, I just wanted to show you this because
it's the first companion robot I’ve wanted
to hug.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
Ohio State researchers have a one-touch organ-healing
device.
The Tissue Nanotransfection technology allows
doctors to generate any cell type within a
patient’s body to repair injured tissue
or restore organs, blood vessels and nerve
cells.
By placing the chip on the body and applying
electrical current, the non-invasive reprogramming
turns skin cells into whatever cells doctors
need.
It injects DNA into the skin cells and it
worked on a mouse to restore blood flow to
a damaged leg in the three weeks.
And they’re beginning human clinical trials
in 2018.
We may have discovered the building blocks
for quantum internet.
Researchers at The Australian National University
used an ion called erbium in a crystal to
store quantum information for over a second.
10,000 times longer than previous experiments.
It also works with existing fibre optic networks
and can connect to different quantum computers.
And one great advantage of developing the
quantum internet is security - it would allow
for information to be destroyed if intercepted.
There is a pen that can detect cancer in real
time.
The MasSpec Pen, developed at the University
of Texas at Austin, works by delivering a
water droplet to a tissue surface which extracts
biomolecules which are then delivered to a
mass spectrometer for molecular analysis.
The system then tells surgeons whether the
tissue is cancerous or not in seconds, allowing
for safer and more effective cancer-removal
surgery.
The first winged mammals evolved 100 million
years earlier than the first modern mammal
fliers.
Two 160 million year old, Jurassic period
fossils, were uncovered in China and a collaboration
between The University Of Chicago and Beijing
Museum of Natural History resulted in these
awesome reconstructions.
And this discovery shows the ecological diversity
of early mammals, suggesting dinosaurs were
not quite as dominant as previously thought.
Neurable created the first brain-controlled
virtual reality game.
The brain-computer interface company
interprets brain activity using an EEG to
measure electric activity and software to
translate it into action.
Their device uses seven electrodes that measure
signals responding to stimuli so that you
can play their game Awakenings without controllers.
You literally just use your brain.
The plan is to make this available in VR arcades
next year.
Meanwhile in Japan, rural elderly folks are
getting around in autonomous robot buses.
They’ve begun experimenting with driverless
buses to shuttle the elderly to medical and
shopping services in rural areas without enough
workers to drive taxis or buses.
Right now the robot shuttle tops out at 6
mph (10 kph) so hopefully as the develop the
technology they can improve the travel time
before their projected launch in 2020.
Nanobiotics are a new class of antibiotics.
Engineers from Michigan University can create
nanoparticles 1/100th the size of a germ of
different shapes to control what they do.
So by using these to coat medical devices
they bind to the proteins to prevent molecules
from changing - thereby creating bacteria
resistance.Which could be a huge advance in
the fight against antibiotic resistance.
Scientists at The University Of Texas at Dallas
have developed electricity-generating yarn.
The carbon nanotube twistron yarn generates
electricity when stretched and one of the
future uses of this technology could be harvesting
energy from ocean waves.
Finally, SMART self-driving wheelchairs are
continuing their development with hospitals
trials in Singapore.
The technology will give people much more
flexibility and much richer personal mobility.
And at the same time it will make it better
for doctors and the nurses who focus on patient
care and will be less worried about whether
they have the right object or the right people
in the right place.
Over the years, Mind Blow has focused on breakthrough
ideas, discoveries and science to push us
all forward.
The world has been on an incredible path of
progress – in our lifetimes we've witnessed
the biggest decrease in poverty, disease and
child deaths.
But progress is not inevitable.
So the Gates Foundation is creating the Goalkeepers
report, which they hope will inspire a new
generation of leaders – Goalkeepers who
raise awareness of progress, hold their leaders
accountable and drive action to accelerate
progress.
Education is an area where the world doesn’t
have enough data to understand progress.
It’s relatively easy to count the number
of children in school, but that doesn’t
tell us how much those children are actually
learning.
Many countries don’t generate any useful
learning data at all, let alone in a comparable
way.
We need to know early whether children are
able to read, a pre-requisite to all learning.
For more information on ways to get involved
in ensuring quality education to transform
our world click the link to read the report.
Now I’m gonna leave you with two walking
robots taking a stroll through the Agility
Robitics office - and as always thanks for
watching.
The art of bookmaking is older than printing
by many centuries.
Yet, today's members of the brotherhood of
book binders, artists of the AF of L CIO are
able to supply man for the most important
ingredient of the modern world -- literacy.
Following a craft as ancient as cave drawings,
these union workers of the book industry are
second to none in keeping pace with progress.
The ingenuity which has passed on to the folders,
gatherers, sewers, trimmers, liners and case
makers, in a proud profession is constantly
at work for you to produce our greatest treasure,
knowledge.